في الإمارات العربية المتحدة حيث لا يوجد ثلج ، فإنهم
يجعلونه لا يمطرون ، وفي أرض جافة بلا أنهار يصنعونها ،
هذه ليست سوى ثاني مرة يراها السلام على ضفاف النهر
على الإطلاق ، ولا حتى
قبطان ركوب الرمث الجديد في الإمارات العربية المتحدة حقيقيًا
سيكون أكبر اختبار هو الحياة
، التحدي الكبير هو رفع علمنا
لأعلى مثل الموجة العالية التي يبلغ عمرها 33
عامًا وتأتي من مدينة تسمى إيلين ، إنها
واحة خضراء على مدار العام توفر
بقية شبه الجزيرة العربية هناك
لم يتغير حجم الشريط الطبيعي للأنهار على الإطلاق
في عام 2010 عندما تدخل مطور محلي طموح
في العنصر الوحيد
الذي يمكننا أن نرى أنه يفتقد
إلى الشاطئ لأنه لا يوجد شاطئ في
مدينة الأسد لأنه بحد ذاته يتدرب
عليه في منتصف  هذا ليس ممتعًا للغاية
و 418 أكلًا على طول إيقاع من صنع الإنسان
وصفت بأنها أطول مدينة ترفيهية في العالم
تكلف أكثر من 15 مليون دولار
بالمياه التي يمكن تشغيلها
بمفتاح صغير
[موسيقى]
إنها حقًا سريعة تستحق ما يكفي
الرياضيون إلى trai  على هذا
النحو ، هبطت إيلين في بطولة العالم للتجديف لعام 2016 ،
لذلك بدأ التدريب ست
ساعات يوميًا لمدة ستة أسابيع مع ميزة الميدان المنزلي ،
حيث يدرسون كل منعطف في كل خريف
، وحتى كمبتدئين هم واثقون من
الفوز ، أعتقد أنه لن يمتص هذا
القليل.  الرجل النموذجي ، كل ما نحتاجه من الوقت ،
تحولت الإثارة إلى خيبة أمل ولكن
هناك القليل من الوقت لذلك سعيد
يبحث بالفعل عن العام المقبل ،
وكان المدربون يسألونني مثل هل
ستعود مرة أخرى هنا اتصلت بهم كل يوم